علي الهرشه السابعه كان له صدى كبير على
السوشيال ميديا
رغم ان يعني المسلسل ما فيهوش صراع كبير
او بلاط كبير او بتشوف كانت ايه العوامل
اللي ادت لده اعتقد كل العناصر كانت
متوفره وكل العناصر اللي كريم بيختارها من
تصوير ومزيكا والكتابه اللي موجوده اصلا
بتاعه اشراف مريم نعوم
ودينا نجمه وكل ده هو الفارق بنسبه كبيره
جدا في
فده بالنسبه لي كان اللي فارق معي في
شخصيه سلمى ان انا اعرف هي مرت بايه زمان
عشان توصل لده ايه ردود الافعال اللي جات
لك واقعي اكتر حاجه سمعت الناس بتتكلم
عليها على الواقعيه ودي مش حاجه بالضروره
كنت متخيلها من الاول ان ده هيبقى ده
هيبقى ده تعليق متكرر في تعليق التاني
الخوف من الجواز دي حاجه برضو ما كنتش
متخيله خالص
بصراحه يعني الناس
انا بالنسبه لي الاحلى انه انه حد يقول
انه ان الشخصيه دي شبه حاجه في حياتي او
حد في حياتي او بتفكرني بعلاقتي او خليتنا
نركز ونحط خط تحت حاجه معينه كده في
علاقتي مع جوزي او مع بنتي او قد ايه مثلا
الوضوء هاتي حاجه مهمه في العلاقه او انه
العلاج النفسي دي حاجه مهمه حتى لو بعد
سنين طويله قوي يعني كل الحاجات دي كانت
بالنسبه لي مؤشرات للنجاح بشكل عام
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقي ات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات